[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen an meiner seite ist für den
sport katja stresow ein schirm genannt
und wir haben unter anderem diese themen
für sie
immer mehr omikron fälle in europa noch
ist unklar wie gefährlich die neue krone
variante ist
schweizer für corona beschränkungen die
volksabstimmung wird zum dämpfer für in
skeptiker
und zwei deutsche fliegen aufs podest
platz zwei und drei beim weltcup
skispringen in finnland
erst seit freitag ist omikron richtig
bekannt seither tauchen weltweit immer
mehr fälle dieser corona variante auf in
hessen hat sich bei einem
reiserückkehrer aus südafrika der
verdacht bestätigt in bayern und in
nordrhein westfalen gibt es weitere
verdachtsfälle
noch steht nicht fest welche
auswirkungen diese variante tatsächlich
hat doch die besorgnis ist groß ines
trams hat mir
flughafen frankfurt die die hier mit
flügen aus dem südlichen afrika ankommen
sind entweder deutsche oder rückkehrer
die in deutschland leben andere werden
nicht mehr mitgenommen
reisebeschränkungen wegen der neuen
virus variante uni konnten
die europäischen behörden in
alarmstimmung mindestens 13 reisende aus
südafrika die hier in amsterdam landeten
wurden positiv auf das neue virus
getestet sie sind nun in einem
flughafenhotel in quarantäne
omikron eine hoch ansteckende variante
die sich schnell verbreitet
davon ausgehen dass die impfstoffe nicht
perfekt wirken somit ist das also sehr
besorgniserregend in der summe
wahrscheinlich ansteckender
wahrscheinlich auch etwas also
schwieriger für die geimpften und ich
glaube nicht an einen leichteren verlauf
lange schlangen wie hier in hamburg an
den improvisierten impfstellen die neue
virusvariante veranlasst nochmals mehr
menschen sich impfen zu lassen einige
zum ersten mal ich hab gedacht das
dass wir nicht diese ausmaße kriegen die
wir jetzt haben und dass das ganze ein
bisschen in die normalen rahmen verläuft
und im endeffekt dass man auch drumherum
kommen hatten wir gründlich die hände
gewaschen den mund gespült
abends bahnsteig wodka getrunken wenn
durch bis auf die knochen vom regen und
schnee und einfach unmöglich eine
zumutung dass man die impfzentren
geschlafen hat einige kirchen wollen
diese lücke schließen impfangebot heute
am rande des advents gottesdienstes im
keller der dresdner frauenkirche die
kirche will keinen ausschließen vertritt
aber einen klaren standpunkt
kirche ist für alle da aber natürlich
nicht für alle überzeugungen und bei
manchen überzeugungen die von menschen
die sich nicht impfen lassen geäußert
werden muss kirche dann auch klar sagen
da können wir nicht mit der
bundespräsident wendet sich heute mit
einem dringenden appell an die nation
und er ruft dazu auf freiwillig kontakte
einzuschränken um einen lock down zu
verhindern wichtig ist dass wir jetzt
alle gemeinsam handeln halten wir uns an
die regeln reduzieren wir noch einmal
unsere kontakte tun wir es damit schulen
und kitas nicht wieder schließen damit
wir das öffentliche leben nicht wieder
vollständig herunterfahren müssen tun
wir es vor allem um menschenleben zu
retten
derweil verlegt die luftwaffe nochmals
fünf patienten aus bayern um die
intensivstationen dort zu entlasten drei
viertel aller krankenhäuser in
deutschland können den normalbetrieb
inzwischen nicht mehr aufrechterhalten
das deutsche gesundheitssystem gerät
immer stärker unter druck auch weil das
personal fehlt wichtige zahlen und
hintergründe zur lage auf den
intensivstationen finden sie online in
unserer zdf heute app die neue
virusvariante breitet sich offenbar
schnell aus immer mehr länder melden
omikron fälle darunter auch dänemark
belgien italien und tschechien
israel hat deswegen die grenzen für alle
ausländer geschlossen dort ist ein
omikron fall bestätigt einen
verdachtsfall gibt es auch in österreich
wo gestern abend zehntausende menschen
gegen die geplante impfpflicht
testierten in den niederlanden gilt
generell wegen der hohen
infektionszahlen ein lockdown ab 17 uhr
bei uns sehen die aktuellen zahlen so
aus das robert koch institut meldet 44
1401 neuinfektionen binnen 24 stunden
1674 mehr als vor einer woche 104
todesfälle kamen hinzu die sieben tage
incidents steigt auf 446 7 in der
schweiz haben im skeptiker versucht mit
hilfe einer volksabstimmung die 3g
beschränkungen zu beenden ohne erfolg
eine klare mehrheit ist dafür dass auch
weiterhin restaurants und co nur mit 3g
nachweis besucht werden dürfen die
inzidenz liegt bei den schweizern höher
als bei uns mit 523 4 die impfquote ist
etwas niedriger sie beträgt 66,9 prozent
petra otto über ein gespaltenes land
noch nie haben sie das parlamentsgebäude
sichern müssen bei einer volksabstimmung
doch die polizei befürchtet
ausschreitungen
das heutige co wied referendum spaltet
die schweiz braucht man zukünftig um
beispielsweise ins restaurant zu dürfen
dieses zertifikat geimpft genesen
getestet 62 prozent der schweizerinnen
und schweizer sagten heute ja
wir vor um die deutliche zustimmung dass
jetzt auch rückendeckung besteht für die
pandemie bekämpfung und auch den kampf
gegen krieg news die gegner zwar in der
minderheit aber laut seit wochen obwohl
in der schweiz die korona maßnahmen viel
lockerer sind als anderswo das
zertifikat sei eine versteckte
impfpflicht der staat werde zu mächtig
sagen sie vor allem auf dem land in dem
deutschsprachigen regionen votierten sie
mit nein es geht natürlich hier jetzt
um die freiheit in dem sing und nicht
nur
um die impfung
es ist alles so extrem gespalten
innerhalb von familien und auch im
freundeskreis
da geht fast unter dass das schweizer
volk heute auch die pflegeberufe
gestärkt hat auf dem stimmzettel für
mehr geld eine gute ausbildung und vor
allem für bessere arbeitsbedingungen
die priorität liegt zu wenig auf der
zeit die man für die patienten brauchen
darf und das möchte ich gerne dass das
sich endet wie sie stimmten rund 60
prozent der wahlberechtigten für die
pflege initiative der staat muss das nun
umsetzen egal was es kostet
eine wichtige weichenstellung gibt es in
der berliner landespolitik der
koalitionsvertrag zwischen spd grünen
und linken ist perfekt morgen soll er
vorgestellt werden regierende
bürgermeisterin soll die frühere spd
familienministerin
franziska giffey werden nach abschluss
der verhandlungen zeigte sie sich
erleichtert und versprach sich mit aller
kraft für eine gute regierungsarbeit
einzusetzen
möglicherweise noch heute könnten die
tarifverhandlungen für den öffentlichen
dienst der länder zum abschluss kommen
es geht um mehr gehalt für erzieherinnen
polizistinnen oder auch für beschäftigte
an unikliniken
man bewege sich aufeinander zu liege
aber noch weit auseinander heißt es aus
verhandlungskreisen
die arbeitgeber hätten jetzt ein angebot
vorgelegt die gewerkschaften hatten fünf
prozent mehr geld gefordert
traditionell zum heutigen ersten advent
haben die beiden großen kirchen mit zwei
gottesdiensten ihre weihnachts
spendenaktionen gestartet beim
katholischen hilfswerk adveniat steht in
diesem jahr die not der armen in den
städten lateinamerikas und der karibik
im mittelpunkt bei der evangelischen
organisation brot für die welt die
klimagerechtigkeit eine welt ein klima
eine zukunft so das motto
damit sind wir beim wintersport und
erfolgreichen skispringen in der
eiseskälte finnlands es war so kalt bei
fast minus 20 grad in ruka sind karl
geiger und markus eisenbichler aufs
podest gesprungen es war zum schluss mal
wieder eine kleine windlotterie den
sechser mit superzahl hatte heute der
slowene anze lange
jak2 deutsche feiern im eiskalten
finnland karl geiger holt sich mit einem
überragenden zweiten sprung in ruka
platz zwei und verteidigt damit auch das
gelbe trikot des führenden im
gesamtweltcup markus eisenbichler wird
bei ständig drehenden winden polarkreis
dritter sein sprung und der schwierigen
bedingungen sieger der slowene anze
janitschek für ihn der erste
weltcup-sieg überhaupt
im eiskanal sind die deutschen
athletinnen und athleten zur zeit kaum
zu stoppen in sotschi russland machten
die rodler johannes ludwig und felix
loch nach dem ersten lauf sage und
schreibe 19 beziehungsweise 14 plätze
gut und sicherten sich rang eins und
zwei und beim bob-weltcup in innsbruck
hat francesco friedrich auch die
entscheidung im viererbob gewonnen und
bei den frauen da gab es einen deutschen
doppelerfolg im zweierbob hier gewann
laura nolte vor kim kalli
zum fußball im ersten sonntagsspiel der
fußball bundesliga schießt eintracht
frankfurt gegen union berlin das
entscheidende tor in der fünften minute
der nachspielzeit 2 1 der endstand und
noch dies gute nachrichten aus houston
texas wo timo boll im halbfinale der
tischtennis wm steht und damit
mindestens bronze sicher hatte boll
kämpft im viertelfinale nicht nur gegen
den us-amerikaner kenny klar sondern
auch gegen eine schmerzende
bauchmuskelzerrung aber der 40 jährige
biss sich durch und gewann schließlich
mit 4 zu 2 sätzen heute nacht trifft er
auf den schwedischen nachwuchs-star
tools vor gott und der ist nur 19 jahre
alt also knapp halb so alt wir drücken
die daumen
dankeschön katja die kommenden tage
werden nass kalt und rutschig manche
bekommen auf sonne und schnee am sonntag
zeigt sich im nordwesten die sonne sonst
ist es eiskalt mit regen und
schneeschauern teils mit glätte die
temperaturen zwischen -3 grad im allgäu
und plus 6 grad an der nordsee am
dienstag fällt bei 0 bis 9 grad im süden
viel schnee später wie in der mitte auch
regen im heute journal spricht claus
kleber um viertel vor zehn mit dem
virologen christian drosten wir wünschen
ihnen einen guten start in die neue
woche sagen tschüss bis morgen und
empfehlen jetzt berlin direkt und theo
koll